Edouard asks if you could go back to
your early 20s would you prioritize help
or was neglecting it necessary to get
where you are today
Edward great question I wanted to
address this one of the great things in
the show I keep saying is that I'm gonna
answer questions I haven't been able to
answer and so thanks for all of you of
getting me to 21 but the other thing I
get to do is clear up some things so
we're picking some questions I think I
sent this one to you Steve right yeah we
get to clarify on the show this is the
clarity our my friends we get to clarify
a little bit on this show and what we
are going to clarify is this I bet you a
lot of people are going to think I'm
gonna go in one direction but I'm going
in another the answer is I wish I
prioritized my health I could have slept
one hour less I could have what played
one hour less of Settlers of Catan with
my brother back in the day I could have
worked there's some crazy one I could
have worked one less hour I could have
done a whole lot of things but I should
have found that one hour to do what I've
been doing for the last 65 days and
prioritize my health so if I could go
back I'd be working out and eating the
way I'm doing it now all the way back
since then